man muss kein feuerwehrmann sein um sich
vorstellen zu können dass ein funke
reicht um die natur bei dieser hitze und
trockenheit in brand zu setzen am 17
juli passiert genau das in einem der
schönsten naturgebiete deutschland 2500
quadratmeter wald in der bastei in der
sächsischen schweiz brennen weil
offenbar vier männer draußen rauchen das
glaubt die polizei ein bildreporter wird
zeuge der szene bild veröffentlicht die
fotos und durch zahlreiche
zeugenhinweise konnten die verdächtigen
jetzt geschnappt werden bild reporter
thomas fischer gab den entscheidenden
hinweis sagt der polizeipräsident hatte
ein schrecklicher an die berühmte bastei
in der sächsischen schweiz in flammen
entfernen der unfassbare auslöser vier
junge männer sollen auf einem
felsvorsprung shisha geraucht und so das
verheerende feuer ausgelöst haben bild
reporter thomas fischer war zu diesem
zeitpunkt selbst als besucher vor ort
als er die männer sieht bemerkt er
schnell dass etwas nicht stimmt und an
dem tag bin ich dann doch mal lang
gegangen und hatte mich gewundert dass
auf einem abschnitt wo ja wo man schon
ein stück laufen muss und klettern muss
vier leute 45 leute saßen und da ein
campingtisch aufgebaut hatten zwei stars
standen und das fand ich schon sehr
ungewöhnlich weil wer schleppt so was
auf eine wanderung mit die bastei ist
eine der meistbesuchten
touristenattraktionen in ganz
deutschland eine traumhafte landschaft
vom fels riff aus bekommen besucher eine
nahezu magischen ausblick auf das
elbsandsteingebirge
normalerweise gelten in dem
naturschutzgebiet strenge
schutzvorschriften thomas fischer gibt
der polizei später den entscheidenden
tipp gesehen hatte es waren personen die
südländischen typ die da geraucht hatten
erstmal habe ich mir nichts dabei
gedacht und auch später nicht aber erst
am folgenden tag wo es genau an dieser
stelle gebrannt hatte nachgang hat mich
dann den kollegen darüber aufgeklärt
dass die jedoch mit kohle betrieben
werden und dass es da auch funkenflug
geben könnte und nachdem wir eine
berichterstattung dazu hatten hat sich
die polizei auch dazu gemeldet bei uns
und wollte gerne dieses foto haben was
wir veröffentlicht hatten bei bild und
mit diesem foto sind sie dann den
mutmaßlichen tätern auf die spur
gekommen kurz nach mitternacht das feuer
wird unterhalb der bastei brücke bemerkt
die brücke die täglich hunderte
touristen über die flammen breiten sich
dramatisch aus es brennt lichterloh
2500 quadratmeter natur geschützte
waldfläche brennen 200 jahre alten bäume
tarif lang erst nach zwei tagen konnten
die 119 feuerwehrkräfte das feuer unter
kontrolle bekommen der tatverdacht gegen
über den aus dem irak stammenden männern
erhärtet sich zunehmend der aktuelle
standort sind jetzt die
brandursachenermittler sinnen weiß noch
mal in diesem gebiet gewesen und hat
spuren genommen genau an dieser stelle
wo die shisha raucher unterwegs gewesen
sind und wie wir von bild erfahren haben
wurde auch in diesem bereich shisha
kohle gefunden das in der tat diese vier
männer mutmaßlich dieses feuer ausgelöst
haben deswegen geht auch die
staatsanwaltschaft davon aus und hat
auch ein tatverdacht gegen die männer
aus dem irak auch wenn die polizei nun
die wahrscheinlichen verursacher
gefunden hat der sachschaden bleibt und
der beläuft sich auf rund 50
fatal in einem der schönsten
naturschutzgebiete deutschlands
[Musik]